what's up guys today i'm going to be
doing a little tutorial for you guys on
how to get the best audio for your
videos there's three basic types of
microphones that we use for all our
videos the first one is a shotgun mic
shotgun mic is uh a very directional mic
and whatever you aim it at you'll pick
up that sound it's really good for
on-set work the condenser microphone is
really really good for doing voice-over
or narration the third type of
microphone we use is called a lav
microphone this is a small microphone
that's wirelessly transmitting to a
receiver elsewhere so i can walk around
freely do whatever i want and we don't
need someone like nico here following me
around with a big microphone setup at
all times so let's break down the
shotgun mic you can be aiming at
someone's face for a voice you can aim
it at the ground for like the sound of
an object moving whatever the boom pole
having an extending arm uh you can you
can get one or you can make one by just
taping a microphone to a like a broom or
something like that or a bamboo stick as
we used to do and what that allows you
to do is get in creative spaces do
everything you want and uh get good
audio while doing it shotgun mics work
completely on proximity and that's why
the boom pole is important because as
you'll see if i start walking away from
the shotgun mic here the audio gets
really bad and that's why you need that
arm to be able to get in there and get
on the edge of frame and capture the
best audio the shock mount works by
holding and grasping the microphone
within like a series of like rubber
bands and stuff so that way no physical
objects are hitting it it removes the
sound of your fingers sliding on here
obviously we're trying to mess it up so
you'll hear the bad audio here but it
generally removes the sound of your
hands shaking the microphone and all the
bumps that normally come from moving a
microfilm around a uh wind sock right
now this this will prevent a little bit
of wind but if you're outside in a windy
environment you want something a little
more heavy duty
we're gonna be putting a dead cat on
there basically this just acts as a
barrier to break up the wind and air
and make it so that uh wind doesn't
affect you from uh getting clean audio
there's also an alternative there if
you're in a pinch and you really need
something
uh bundling up some socks on here will
definitely help however these don't work
as well and they will kind of start to
mute your audio a little bit another
reason shotgun mics are great for onset
use is because they are directional it's
actually balancing out the sounds coming
in from the front while trying to mute
out
sounds coming from like sides and behind
it that's what really helps you aim it
and kind of choose which audio source
you want to be picking from that's why
generally you want the microphone to be
above pointing down because then you're
just getting the ground muting all the
audio and the audio from your actor when
you're like this you're going to be
picking up airplanes in the sky and wind
noise and when you're from the side
you're getting all the sound bouncing
off the walls of the room so this is me
talking with it pointed directly at my
face and then as you hear it sounds like
crap and i might as well just get cut on
the camera here because my whole movie's
ruined
cool microphone number two is the
condenser mic the condenser mic is great
as i said for voice over and narration
because you can get really close to it
and you can sound like you're talking in
someone's brain because you're so
present within their ears so to break
down the parts of a condenser mic the
main one is a d popper screen all this
is doing is the same thing that the
windsock or dead cat is it's preventing
the little
little
pieces of like air from going into the
microphone and it's breaking that up if
you don't have one of these or you can't
afford that put a sock on it
when we were recording the voiceover and
narration for freddie and brandon's
metal gear rising video this is actually
the setup we used to record the official
voice over artist who does ryden
but
he didn't seem to mind our third
microphone that we discussed is the lav
microphone it's a small discreet
microphone that you can wear with you
it's really good for events which is why
we use these for lan parties so we can
just hook everyone up and they can walk
around and do whatever and we're always
capturing their voice if you're trying
to be discreet with the amount of camera
gear and people you have on set
sometimes it's really nice to have just
a little hidden microphone on somebody
so that way when you're out on the
street with the camera you don't really
draw that much attention to yourself
each microphone kind of has its own use
and its own place for shooting videos
but the one thing you need to consider
with each one is that they are all
extremely sensitive to general noise and
sounds in the in the environment we can
focus on what we want to listen to so i
can hear someone's voice across the room
if i focus on listening to it but the
microphone can't do that it picks up
everything and anything that's within
its range and you want to close windows
you want to turn off computers if you
have really loud fans and just generally
know that if you can hear a sound the
microphone can probably hear it way
better this is a huge factor with
airplanes vehicles cars so just be aware
of that when using these microphones
hey kid you want to learn some tricks
about audio there's no silence
on film when people stop talking it
doesn't go completely silent that sounds
really weird and that is why it's
important to use room tone while on the
location or set that you're on you want
to record just a few like 10 15 seconds
of just what it naturally sounds like to
be there to fill up little gaps while
editing
there's a lot of stuff going on we have
an open window you can hear the freeway
we have computers with fans that are
louder than a freaking gunshot you
wouldn't probably hear that unless i
stop talking otherwise it sounds a
little bit like this
when there's gaps in my voice
pretty awkward
trick number two we've mentioned this in
a few other videos but we'll mention it
again because it's really useful if you
are really in a pinch and you really
need a microphone or you need to get
someone's clean audio use your own phone
the little microphone in here is
actually really high quality and as long
as the uh proximity is is close to
someone's face or voice you'll be
capturing something pretty good that you
can use the one thing you need to make
sure you're aware of is you'll need to
sync it one other thing a phone can be
really useful for is if you have a
dialogue scene at a table and people are
discussing it's really easy to just set
the phone on the table and hide it and
you get nice and clear audio from people
as long as they aren't smacking the
table let's say we're on set and uh nico
for some reason accidentally messes up
the microphone and doesn't have it
pointed at me i've got to dub everything
i've got to use something that's called
adr you're just essentially re-recording
the voices for everything a lot of
people typically will then move to a
microphone like this because it's a
pretty simple desk setup and they'll
just record the voice like this however
the biggest issue is that these
microphones all interpret sound
completely differently if you want to
make stuff sound natural and sound like
it was actually on set and recorded
there
you'll probably want to use the same
microphone you were recording everything
else with so you don't want to use this
one you actually want to set up this
microphone
on your desk or wherever you want to
record these additional voices and
record all the audio and dialogue with
that and you guys are wondering what
microphones we specifically use we'll
have uh the actual names in the
description but for the most part any
good shotgun mic any condenser mic
mostly any sennheiser lav mic or any
other decent lav mic they all kind of
work the same just don't stress out too
much about which one you're getting lobs
are very expensive because the wireless
technology within them
it's expensive you can probably get used
ones for cheap condenser mics these are
actually i would say some of the most
inexpensive ones it was 60 bucks pretty
reasonable shotgun mics on the other
hand though this one was actually around
250 i've used a couple in my life but
this is the one that i've used the most
that's the one i'm comfortable using
quick odds and ends to think about how
are you recording your audio is it going
straight into your camera are you going
into an external recorder a lot of
cameras can record audio straight into
them but you may find yourself needing
to record into an external recorder
things like the zoom recorders like h4n
or they have a new one those work great
and like we did at the beginning of this
piece when you start rolling roll the
audio roll the camera point them both at
the same thing like an actor or with
those clapboards and just have them
clap that spike is where you can sync up
the audio and everything will work great
there's also programs like pluraleyes
and i think there's stuff actually built
into adobe premiere that will
automatically sync up audio tracks if
you have a scratch audio track from the
camera and a good high quality recording
on an external recorder our microphones
use xlr cables they're super cheap on
monoprice.com some microphones like uh
going into a dslr camera use an eighth
inch connection instead i hope this
answered some of your long running
questions on audio microphones and the
like if you have more questions feel
free to hit us up on twitter maybe even
leave a question in the comments we'll
try and answer everything we can
peace out
you